.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Merci, Adama.
Schon seit vielen Jahren hat
Lotti Latrous das Elend vor Augen.
Doch daran gewöhnen
konnte sie sich nie.
Dann geht es mir so schlecht,
dass ich nur noch weinen könnte.
Ich könnte nur noch weinen.
Ihr Herz schlägt für die Ärmsten
in der Elfenbeinküste.
Tausende Menschen
konnte sie schon vor dem Tod retten.
Que Dieu te le garde.
Ich kann nicht die ganze Welt
retten. Das möchte ich auch nicht.
Der kleine Tropfen auf dem
heissen Stein - den retten wir.
Um diesen geht es,
und nicht um den ganzen Ozean.
Seit 23 Jahren lebt die Schweizerin
im Slum von Abidjan.
Vieles ist seither geschehen.
Was sich alles
in ihrem Leben verändert hat,
davon handelt diese Reportage.
* Sanfte Musik *
Es war 2009 als ich die Schweizerin
zum ersten Mal in Afrika besuchte.
In ihrem damaligen Centre l'Espoir
nahm sie Waisenkinder auf,
deren Eltern an Aids gestorben waren.
Auch ein Ambulatorium
gehörte zum Hilfswerk,
wo Kranke gratis behandelt wurden.
Für Schwerstkranke führte
die Schweizerin ein Sterbehospiz.
Très bien, donc je t'embrasse même.
Tu vois?
Sie waren auch
an Tuberkulose erkrankt.
Haben Sie keine Angst,
sich wieder anzustecken?
Ja, aber ich kann deswegen nicht
einfach mit meiner Arbeit aufhören.
Doch dann wurde sie 2016 fast dazu
gezwungen, ihr Lebenswerk aufzugeben.
Das Centre l'Espoir
ist heute eine Ruine.
* Sanfte Musik *
Wir mussten gehen,
weil der Staat sagte,
dass der Flugplatz
vergrössert werden müsse
und hier Strassen
durchführen würden.
Ich weiss nicht genau, was sie
machen wollten, aber wir erhielten
ein offizielles Dokument
mit der Aufforderung zu gehen.
Aziz Latrous ist Lottis Ehemann.
Es fällt ihm schwer,
an jenen Ort zurückzukehren,
wo einst vielen Leuten
geholfen wurde.
Ich bin traurig,
jetzt ist alles zerstört.
Ich dachte,
andere Leute könnten es nutzen,
aber es kamen Drogenhändler.
Sie verkauften in der Nacht Drogen,
Haschisch, Tabletten und LSD.
Dann kamen die Bulldozer
der Regierung.
Ich war besorgt,
weil ich nicht wusste,
wohin mit dem Zentrum.
Das fiel mir schwer.
Und dann natürlich auch,
mich von den Leuten zu trennen.
Obwohl sie den Slum
schon vor sechs Jahren verlassen hat,
bleibt sie
als Schutzpatronin präsent.
Bonjour! Vous allez bien?
Oui.
* Unverständlich *
Bonjour.
- Bonne arrivée!- Merci.
Sie sind ja ein richtiger Star hier.
Nein, ich würde mich nicht
als Star bezeichnen.
Wir haben uns einfach gern.
Zum Glück
geht diese Geschichte weiter.
Nach langem Suchen fand
das Ehepaar Latrous eine neue Heimat.
Sie liegt in einem Vorort von Abidjan
und heisst
Centre l'Espoir Adjouffou Bassam.
Ich begann, Land zu suchen.
Ich wollte wieder
in einen Slum zurück.
Ich habe lange
nach etwas Passendem gesucht.
Ein afrikanischer Freund
half mir bei der Suche.
Er fand ein Landstück,
und als er es mir zeigte, sagte ich:
"Aber das ist ja sumpfig."
Aber ich sah, dass hinter
diesem Landstück ein Slum lag.
Da wollte sie unbedingt hin.
Aber das sumpfige Land
musste zuerst trockengelegt werden.
Das war dann
die Aufgabe von Ehemann Aziz,
einem pensionierten Bauingenieur.
Es gab viel Wasser hier,
niemand wollte etwas machen.
So haben wir Pfähle
in den Boden gerammt,
um ein Fundament zu konstruieren.
Darauf bauten wir das neue Zentrum.
Das war teurer
als eine normale Konstruktion,
aber wenigstens konnten wir
das Grundstück nutzbar machen.
Und wie Sie sehen:
Wir sind umgeben von einem Slum.
Lotti ist sehr glücklich,
dieses Grundstück gefunden zu haben.
* Sanfte Musik *
In seinem Berufsleben
leitete Aziz zahlreiche Projekte.
Heute ist er
der Technikchef des Hilfswerks.
Ich mache das mit Leidenschaft,
das ist klar.
Aber gleichzeitig bringe ich
den Leuten das Handwerk bei.
Ich werde alt, ich bin 74 Jahre alt.
Vermutlich werde ich
bald seltener hierherkommen.
Deshalb muss ich
mein Wissen weitergeben.
Siehst du, wie gut er das macht?
Mit dem Leim wird es besser halten.
Das neue Centre
wurde im Januar 2017 eröffnet.
Es gibt über 50 Personen eine neue
Heimat, darunter 35 Waisenkindern.
Tu vas bien?
- Oui.
Salut les garçons.
Tout le monde va bien?- Oui.
Regelmässig
kommen Jugendliche zu Besuch,
für die Lotti eine Ersatzmutter ist.
Es sind Waisenkinder,
die im Centre aufgewachsen sind.
Das sind meine Kinder.
Sie waren noch so klein, als du
zuletzt vor zwölf Jahren hier warst.
Das ist Adama. Von ihm machtest du
damals eine Aufnahme.
Und heute ist er so gross.
Adama.
Zwölf Jahre zuvor.
All diese Waisenkinder
fanden Zuflucht bei Lotti.
So auch Adama,
der Bub mit der blauen Tasse.
Was sind das für Kinder?
Das sind auch
unsere Waisenaidskinder.
Dort haben wir die Babys
und hier die mittleren.
Ganz kleine,
die gerade erst angekommen sind.
Das hier
ist ein total unterernährtes Kind.
Dieser Junge
nuckelt chronisch an seinem Daumen.
Wir mussten ihm den Daumen sogar
einbinden, denn wie Sie sehen ...
Wir müssen ihn wieder einbinden.
Er nuckelt ständig an seinem Daumen.
Dieses Kind
ist ganz stark unterernährt.
Er wird sicher
neurologische Schäden haben.
Wenn ein Kind während zwei Jahren
fast nichts zu essen bekommt,
kann sich nichts entwickeln,
auch das Gehirn nicht.
Das ist Jérémie.
Jérémie, tu viens?
Salut, tu vas bien? Oui?
Das ist der Junge,
der an seinem Daumen nuckelte.
Er war damals
etwa anderthalb Jahre alt.
Et puis, tu es grand et gentil
aujourd'hui, non? Oui, voilà.
Er lebt noch immer hier
und geht in eine spezielle Schule.
Er ist sehr intelligent.
Er versteht alles, was man ihm sagt,
und er arbeitet gerne.
Alle, die bei Lotti Latrous
aufgewachsen sind,
machen heute ihren Weg - dank
ihrer finanziellen Unterstützung.
Ange macht eine Patisserie-Lehre,
Boris geht in die Schule,
Laurent macht eine Kochlehre ...
... und Adama studiert Politik.
Aber er möchte später
zur Psychologie wechseln.
Ich kam sterbend hier an.
Ich war neun Jahre alt
und war nahe am Tod.
Mir wurde Liebe gegeben,
Herzlichkeit, Anerkennung.
Teilen habe ich hier gelernt.
All das.
Auch Pflege und Ausbildung
habe ich erhalten.
Einfach alles.
Das Hilfswerk von Lotti Latrous
ist heute grösser denn je.
Auf dem über 7'000 m2 grossen Gelände
gibt es Ð wie schon am alten Ort -
auch ein Ambulatorium.
Bis zu 250 Hilfesuchende
kommen täglich hierher.
Medikamente und
medizinische Beratungen sind gratis.
Moderne Apparaturen
und ausgebildetes Pflegepersonal
unter Leitung von drei Ärzten
betreuen die Kranken.
Die Geräte sind eine Spende
der Schweizer Eidgenossenschaft.
Die fünfjährige Mariam
litt an einer Entzündung des Gehirns.
Daraus entwickelte sich
ein Wasserkopf.
Nun soll dem Mädchen
Blut entnommen werden.
Doch es klappt nicht.
Sie hat zu wenig davon.
Viermal
wurde Mariam bereits operiert.
Ihr Zustand besserte sich nicht.
Lotti Latrous
muss der Mutter nun mitteilen,
dass es für ihr Kind
keine Hoffnung mehr gibt.
Glaubst du an Gott, Mama?
- Ja.
Betest du?
Du hast noch zwei andere Kinder.
Wenn Gott uns ein Kind schenkt,
leiht er es uns nur.
Er schenkt es uns nicht.
Manchmal
sind die Pläne des Herrn anders.
Gott wird sie bald zu sich rufen,
damit sie aufhört zu leiden.
An seiner Seite
wird sie Frieden finden.
Dann gibt es kein Leiden mehr.
Wie ist das für Sie, eine solche
Nachricht zu übermitteln?- Schlimm.
Aber ...
Und deswegen frage ich immer zuerst,
ob sie an Gott glauben.
Ich weiss, dass sie Muslimin ist.
Zuerst frage ich immer,
ob sie an Gott glauben.
Wenn sie mit Ja antworten,
was zu 99,5 % der Fall ist,
weil die Menschen hier gläubig sind,
dann kann ich wenigstens
Gott zur Hilfe nehmen.
In diesem Fall
ist es für mich einfacher,
einer Mutter die Wahrheit zu sagen.
Weil sie schon
auf dem Weg ist zum ...
Sie weiss bereits, dass ihr Kind
früher oder später mal stirbt.
Aber es ist immer wieder schwierig.
Nur wenige Tage nach diesem Gespräch
hat Mariam diese Welt verlassen.
Kostet Sie die Armut, die Sie
täglich sehen, nicht viel Kraft?
Doch, aber ich erhalte auch
immer wieder neue Kraft.
Nach einer Schwierigkeit
kommt immer etwas,
das uns glücklich macht.
Etwas,
das uns zum Weitermachen motiviert.
* Sanfte Musik *
Rund um Lotti Latrous' Oase
breitet sich das Elend aus.
Sie nimmt Adama mit
auf einen Rundgang durch den Slum.
Der heute 22-Jährige
kam als Waisenkind ins Hilfswerk
und wuchs dort auf.
Ich nehme ab und zu Kinder
mit in diese Quartiere,
damit sie wissen,
wie sie in der Realität aussehen.
Orte, woher auch sie stammen,
sich aber nicht mehr
daran erinnern können,
weil sie zu klein waren, als ihre
Eltern starben und sie zu uns kamen.
Sie sollen wissen,
was sie bei uns haben,
welches Glück sie haben, trotz
oder v.a. wegen Aids bei uns zu sein
und all das zu bekommen,
was sie von uns erhalten.
Wenn man all diese Kinder hier
sieht, die überhaupt keine Hoffnung
und kein Morgen haben -
sie müssen das für später wissen.
Fast die Hälfte der Einwohner
der Elfenbeinküste
lebt unter der Armutsgrenze.
Hunderttausende haben nicht genug
zu Essen und keine Arbeit.
Just prendre un café.
C'est bon, maman.
Das berührt mich sehr.
Leute zu sehen, die so leben müssen.
Das treibt mich an,
hart zu arbeiten,
um vorwärtszukommen.
Darum möchte ich
im humanitären Bereich tätig sein,
um Leuten zu helfen,
die so in Armut leben,
wie ich es auch hätte tun müssen.
Viele haben keinen Strom.
Es mangelt an sauberem Trinkwasser
und sanitären Einrichtungen.
Das nennt man Hof.
Ein Hof ist ein Innenhof,
der von vielen Häusern umringt ist.
Es ist kein Königshof, aber eben ...
Das sind die gemeinsame Toilette
und der Duschraum.
Hier leben mindestens zehn Familien.
Jede Familie hat vielleicht
acht Familienangehörige,
oder sagen wir mal fünf.
Also leben 50 Personen
auf so kleinem Raum
und teilen sich
eine Dusche und eine Toilette.
Wie steht es
um die Trinkwasserversorgung?
Schlecht. Hie und da gibt es einen
Wasserhahn - wir sahen vorhin einen.
Aber sonst müssen sie weit gehen,
um Trinkwasser zu holen.
Toi, tu es un petit dragueur.
Tu es charmant comme ça.
Au revoir!
Malaria, Aids und Tuberkulose
sind hier weit verbreitet.
In öffentlichen Krankenhäusern
erhält nur Hilfe, wer bezahlen kann.
Wenig später. Lotti Latrous entdeckt
eine Frau mit einer offenen Wunde.
Du solltest auf jeden Fall
einen Verband machen.
Die Wunde
kann sich komplett infizieren,
und dann
gibt es eine Blutvergiftung.
Du kannst daran sterben.
Du kannst zu uns kommen,
wir reinigen die Wunde
und verbinden sie.
Bist du einverstanden?
Es kostet dich nichts.
Doch die Frau
taucht nie im Ambulatorium auf.
Sie vertraue der modernen Medizin
nicht, liess sie ausrichten.
Am meisten fürchten sich die Menschen
in den Slums vor einer Krankheit,
die alle nur "La Maladie" nennen.
Gemeint ist Aids.
Im Jahre 2009
starben im Centre l'Espoir jede Woche
bis zu fünf Menschen an Aids.
Von diesen Frauen hier überleben
vielleicht gerade mal drei.
Die anderen sterben.
Wie geht es dir?
Sie will sich hinlegen.
Ich helfe dir.
Wir drehen sie ein bisschen.
Es ist vorbei.
Die Frau hiess Jeanine.
Sie wurde gerade einmal 28 Jahre alt.
* Sanfte Musik *
Lotti Latrous
stand schon unzähligen Menschen
während ihrer letzten Stunden bei.
Am Anfang
habe ich total mit Gott gehadert.
Ich verstand nicht, weshalb Gott uns
all diese Kinder und Mütter,
all diese Menschen wegnimmt.
Doch dann merkte ich, dass
solche Gedanken gar nichts bringen,
dass das alles
nur negative Gedanken waren.
Und dann sagte ich mir:
"Das ist jetzt einfach so."
Ich habe in Afrika gelernt,
dass alles, was Gott macht, gut ist.
Auch im neuen Zentrum
befindet sich eine Klinik.
Doch Lotti Latrous nennt diese
nicht mehr wie früher Sterbespital.
Dank besserer Medikamente
überleben heute viel mehr Menschen
Krankheiten wie Aids.
Du kannst dein Bein hier drauflegen.
Ganz vorsichtig.
Ist das einfach ein Liebesdienst
oder auch medizinisch nützlich?
Ein Liebesdienst an wen?
An sie oder an mich?
Das müssen Sie beantworten.
An uns beide.
Nein, es ist nichts Medizinisches.
Das ist ein ...
Wenn man sie zu fest berührt,
tut es ihr weh.
Also streichle ich sie einfach.
Diese Menschen wurden schon
seit Jahren nicht mehr gestreichelt.
Niemand berührt sie mehr.
Warum denn nicht?
- Wegen ihrer Aidserkrankung.
Die Menschen fürchten,
man könnte sich anstecken,
wenn man einander nur schon
anschaut, sich gemeinsam unterhält,
oder wenn man
aus demselben Teller isst.
Geht es?
Mache ich dir nicht weh?
Sicher?
Es geht mir darum,
diesen Menschen
ihre Würde zu erhalten,
ihnen ihre Würde zurückzugeben.
Diesen Menschen zu sagen:
"Du bist genauso wichtig wie ich."
Alles hat ein Ende, sowohl das Gute
als auch das Schlechte.
Eines Tages
wird es dir besser gehen.
Mach dir keine Sorgen.
Ich mache das nicht,
damit ich ein gutes Gefühl habe.
Die Menschen haben ein Recht darauf.
Ich muss das machen.
Das hat nichts
mit meinen Gefühlen zu tun,
das muss gemacht werden.
Und wenn jemand die Gelegenheit hat,
das zu machen, muss er es machen.
In der Schweiz blieb ihr Einsatz
im Slum von Abidjan nicht unbemerkt.
2004 durfte Lotti Latrous eine
hohe Auszeichnung entgegennehmen.
Die Schweizerin des Jahres 2004:
Lotti Latrous.
Welch ein Moment für eine Frau,
die nie einen Beruf erlernt hat.
Von da an
ist sie eine Ikone der Schweiz.
Der Angelpunkt der Familie Latrous
war damals ein Haus unweit von Genf.
Wenn Lotti in der Schweiz war,
kamen jeweils alle zu Besuch.
Hier trug sie zum ersten Mal
ihren Enkel Sinai in den Armen.
Die Familie lebte bis um die Jahr-
tausendwende in der Elfenbeinküste.
Kurz nachdem Lotti
ihr Hilfswerk gegründet hatte,
wurde ihr Mann Aziz von seiner Firma
nach Ägypten versetzt.
Dort brauchte man den Tunesier
als Leiter für ein Ingenieurprojekt.
Er und die drei Kinder gingen
nach Kairo, Lotti blieb in Abidjan.
Eine Entscheidung,
unter der sie litt.
Was schmerzt denn noch?
Dass ich es
nicht anders machen konnte.
Dass ich diese Wahl
treffen musste und dass ...
Dass ich von meiner Familie
verlangen musste,
mich gehen zu lassen.
Wenn wir alle an demselben Ort
miteinander hätten leben können ...
Das war das Schwierige:
Dass ich von ihnen verlangen musste,
mich gehen zu lassen.
Dass ich ihnen
Schmerzen zufügen musste.
Dass ich ihnen sagen musste,
dass ich nicht mehr mit ihnen
unter einem Dach leben möchte,
sondern dass sie mich
gehen lassen müssen.
Dass ich egoistisch war
und so viel von ihnen verlangt
und erwartet habe,
um mein eigenes Glück zu verfolgen.
Unter der Trennung litt v.a. Sarah,
die neun Jahre alt war,
als die Mutter ging.
Sie hat sich so entschieden,
ich denke nicht darüber nach.
Nie?
- Nein.
Doch die Wunden
waren damals noch nicht verheilt.
Sarah verliess weinend den Raum.
Sie war damals erst neun Jahre alt.
Und dass tief in ihrem Herzen ...
Wenn es so hervorkommt,
wie es halt manchmal passiert -
dass es ihr einfach
noch immer wehtut.
Dass ich mal eben nicht da war,
als sie mich
vielleicht gebraucht hätte.
Heute ist auch Sarah
Teil dieser Grossfamilie.
Sarah hat sich uns
inzwischen auch angeschlossen.
Sie hat alles akzeptiert
und v.a. auch verstanden.
Sie liebt diese Kinder
genauso wie ihre Geschwister.
Sie nennt sie übrigens
ihre kleinen Brüder und Schwestern.
Sie ist auch
in die Stiftung eingestiegen.
Sie kommt zwei-
bis dreimal pro Jahr vorbei.
Doch, es geht ihr gut.
Was bedeutet es Ihnen, dass Sarah
heute alles nicht nur akzeptiert,
sondern auch mitmacht?
Es war noch das Letzte, das fehlte.
Jetzt ist einfach alles perfekt.
Lottis Ehemann Aziz Latrous
ist im Hilfswerk nicht nur
für das Technische zuständig.
Er hat noch weit mehr Fähigkeiten.
Sind Sie der Koch hier?
Ja.
Ich bin der Boss in der Küche.
Im Leben ist es nicht wichtig,
wer der Chef ist.
Es ist wichtiger, eine
ausgeglichene Beziehung zu führen,
als immer zu schauen,
wer der Boss ist.
Ist es manchmal schwierig,
mit Lotti zusammen zu sein?
Sie ist doch sehr willensstark.
- Ja, klar.
Da kommt sie gerade.
Manchmal ist es schwierig,
aber nicht immer.
Ich fragte ihn gerade,
ob es manchmal schwierig sei,
mit Ihnen zusammen zu sein.
Die Frage ist,
wer es mit wem schwierig hat.
Wir sind unterschiedliche Charaktere
und sind nicht immer
derselben Meinung.
Und ...
Aber jetzt sind wir schon
seit 49 Jahren verheiratet.
Jetzt haben wir
einander kennengelernt.
Wenn sie sich
etwas in den Kopf gesetzt habe,
könne sie sehr stur sein, sagt Aziz.
Und wenn einmal
etwas nicht nach Plan laufe,
verliere sie
schnell einmal die Nerven.
So, jetzt hör auf mit Filmen,
ich bin müde!
Weil das Hilfswerk der Schweizerin
in den letzten Jahren
immer grösser wurde,
benötigt es auch mehr Geld.
100'000 Fr. sind es monatlich,
die dank Spendengeldern
aus der Schweiz zusammenkommen.
Lotti Latrous beschäftigt heute
über 80 Mitarbeitende.
Darauf bin ich stolz.
83 Menschen können mit diesem Lohn
in Würde leben.
Stolz ist die Schweizerin
aus Regensberg
auch auf ihr neustes Projekt.
Das ist unser Dörflein.
Wir bauten es
während der Covid-Zeit.
Aziz war in der Schweiz
und ich blieb hier.
Ich rannte in Schutzkleidung
hin und her,
um sicherzustellen,
dass alles nach Plan läuft.
Dieses Dörflein haben wir für
alte und behinderte Personen gebaut.
In den 13 Häuschen
leben etwas mehr als 20 Menschen.
Auch diese dreiköpfige Familie
hat hier ein neues Zuhause gefunden.
Samuel ist gelähmt.
Weshalb ist er im Rollstuhl?
Er fiel
von einer Kokospalme herunter.
(Samuel antwortet auf Deutsch,
Lotti Latrous hilft ihm.)
Ich bin von einer Kokospalme
heruntergefallen.
Was hast du denn dort gesucht?
Tu as compris ce que je t'ai dit?
- Oui, tu m'as demandé
qu'est-ce que j'allais faire
sur le cocotier.
Tu étais cherché une noix de coco,
bien sûr.
Also, was hast du denn auf diesem
blöden Kokosnussbaum gemacht?
Regarde-moi quand tu parles!
Bon ...
Ich ...
Ich hatte ...
... Hunger.
Du hattest Hunger.
Du wolltest
eine Kokosnuss zum Essen holen.
Tu as voulu chercher
une noix de coco pour manger.
Oui, pour manger.
- Ein hoher Preis.
Bereust du es?
Bon ...
Ich weiss es nicht.
Nichts im Leben
geschieht ohne Grund.
Dank dieses Unglücks
habe ich Lotti kennengelernt.
Es nützt nichts, wenn man es bereut.
Man akzeptiert sein Schicksal,
wie es kommt.
Genau, bereuen bringt nichts.
Ça nous avance pas.
Dank Lottis Engagement
kann der 29-jährige Samuel
nun die Matura nachholen,
mit Spezialfach Deutsch.
(Samuel spricht Deutsch)
Ich mag Mama Lotti so gern.
Sie ist meine Lieblingsmama.
Mama Lotti hilft mir ...
... viel.
Danke an ...
Dank ihr
kann ich heute zur Schule gehen.
Seit der Gründung des Hilfswerks
vor 23 Jahren
haben Hunderttausende Menschen
wieder eine Perspektive gefunden.
So auch Bergarbeiter Frank,
der bei einem Minenunglück
schwer verletzt wurde.
Er verlor ein Bein.
Er hat nur noch ein Bein,
aber was noch schlimmer ist:
Seine Wirbelsäule wurde geschädigt.
Er ist heute gelähmt
und hat ein amputiertes Bein.
Bleibt er nun hier im Dörflein,
oder welche Lösung gibt es für ihn?
Nein, er will unbedingt
einen Beruf erlernen.
Wir haben zuerst geschaut,
was er machen könnte.
Aber er hat
keine grosse Schulausbildung.
Er hat sich dafür entschieden,
zu lernen,
wie man Tuareg-Schmuck macht.
Jetzt haben wir einen Tuareg
gefunden, der ihm das beibringt.
Und so erhält er nun
zweimal die Woche Unterricht.
68 Jahre alt
ist sie inzwischen geworden.
Noch ist sie voller Tatendrang
und mit Herzblut dabei.
Aber auch ihre Energien
sind nicht unerschöpflich.
Super, je suis contente.
Uh, ich werde alt.
Ich kann fast nicht mehr aufstehen.
Möchten Sie mal kürzertreten?
- Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Wenn wir jemanden finden,
der das übernehmen möchte
und in unserem Geist weitermacht -
das ist die Voraussetzung,
dass der Geist erhalten bleibt ...
Jemand, bei dem wir - Aziz, Marie
Odile und ich - das Gefühl haben:
"Doch, es ist die Person,
auf die wir gewartet haben."
Dann müssen wir
diese Person zuerst mal einführen,
und das braucht sicher ein Jahr.
Jemanden zu finden, der das
mit demselben Geist weiterführt -
das ist wahrscheinlich schwierig.
Wir vertrauen auf den lieben Gott.
Wir vertrauen ihm.
* Rhythmische Trommelmusik
und Klatschen *
Wo andere sich Sorgen machen würden,
glaubt Lotti Latrous
an eine Fügung des Schicksals.
Daraus schöpft sie ihre Kraft,
um armen Menschen beizustehen.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022
Merci!
* Applaus *